you're in uh the new hobbit film and you
play
the dragon smaug i do i do and uh we had
evangeline lily here i think it was a
week ago it seems like yesterday and
she she uh
she corrected she said i said smaug
correctly and that i was one of the only
smiles yeah yeah that's that's how i've
been told to say it
you studied reptiles for this role
a little bit yeah no i just i wanted to
sort of um you know
obviously i needed to humanize him a
little bit he's this mythical
fire-breathing
serpent you can fly so you can also
speak english so there needs to be some
kind of humanity to him yeah but at the
same time i wanted to honor some of the
sort of animalistic side of him and uh
yeah i guess like a sort of eager uh
actor
student i went to the uh the london zoo
in regent's park and looked at the
reptile house looked at kimono dragons
and
serpents and even bats as well because
he has wings
um and thought what can i bring to the
floor of a motion capture stage because
that's how we began to create this is
what's fascinating
i wasn't aware when i first heard that
you were going to be the voice i thought
you'd exclusively be the voice of the
dragon and then i
found out and you're fantastic at it
that you
also said let me be i can do the body
motions as well
i just figured it would make sense to
have the voice a voice coming from a
body that was in motion and so it didn't
feel too disjointed because it's the
most extraordinary creation that weta
you know the digital department peter's
um studio has has created and it is
phenomenal
it looks very different from me which is
a very good thing but um
it's uh it i just wanted to sort of give
some anthropomorphic qualities of it
some facial
movements and emotions and temperatures
and sort of speeds of movement that were
what did you learn about reptiles like
that you could teach me or or a dragon
or is there anything i mean well no this
is
what i'm doing right now is probably a
salsa
slow salsa i'm a dragon doing a salsa
yeah
that's my dragon that's right i don't
know if there's anything you could do
that would
you know help me or in the face that you
do it or is it
a bit of both yeah so you can kind of if
you just lean on your on your elbows a
little bit and then
kind of just hyper extend your neck to
the point that you'll need some
um yeah you'll need some physical
therapy after and yeah
he's very good and now and i just sort
of a bit more still they're very still
for a long time
i'm a very hyperactive dragon you are
yeah i'm a dragon that's had a lot of
cough
a whole load of caffeine yeah and
[Laughter]
yeah like it's like a young male ginger
male street
that's totally what i was going for wow
i was channeling ginger meryl street
you knocked it out thank you so much
[Applause]
uh we have a uh we have a clip here uh
from
the hobbit and this is the first time
that smog
is seen cool and it's very uh it's quite
a dramatic wow they're letting you show
that cool
normally yeah they'd said no and i said
you know hello brian hello hello then
they hung up
and well i prefer to see this than me
naked in a shower because at least this
lesson
well we'll see we'll see what the
viewers prefer take a look
[Music]
huh
[Music]
don't be shy
[Applause]
what a great sinister quality i mean
obviously there's there's some
effects but you're thinking there's such
a process but but the sinister quality
to your voice oh thank you yeah have you
always known you could do that
yeah yeah since a young child my parents
are terrified of me
i will not
voted most likely to do evil